okay now it is time to have an important
and difficult and controversial
discussion we've talked about the
assassination by a police officer
unclear on duty off-duty from Turkey of
the Russian ambassador to Turkey the
yells of Allahu Akbar and of don't for
this is for Aleppo this is for Syria
allegedly an individual according to the
mayor of Ankara who is associated with a
radical Islamist terrorist group we've
talked about the truck massacre in
Berlin and the initial allegations that
this was a Pakistani refugees seeking
asylum in Germany although now that has
been called into question by German
authorities who say we may have the
wrong person also had the discussion
about how the mo the style of the attack
is similar to not only the type of
attack that we know Isis encourages
through training manuals and training
materials that have been discovered but
also that was perpetrated in Nice France
over the summer so all of that being
said how can we have a conversation
about the role that Islam plays in
terrorist acts perpetrated by individual
Muslims now the reason I bring this up
is that there are some who hesitate to
ever use the term Islamic terror or
radical Islam and there are even
individuals who go further and I get
emails from some of them who say David
even if a Muslim perpetrates an act of
terror and says that they did it because
of Islam it still doesn't actually have
anything to do with Islam I think we
have to break this down into a few
different elements and and sort of
logical fallacies number one do we have
some duty to believe what the
perpetrators say so taking for example
the instance of the Russian ambassador
being killed by a Turkish police officer
alleged to be a member of F eto a
radical Islamist a terrorist group the
perpetrator referenced Allah during the
attack is an alleged member of an
Islamic terror group referenced a
theater where Muslims died as the
inspiration for his
referring of course to aleppo at the
hands of Russian weapons and still some
will say well that has nothing to do
with Islam that doesn't make any sense
to me that does not seem like a logical
analysis to me and to give an example of
there's this a horrific ritual that a
very small percentage of Orthodox Jews
practice around circumcision which
involves using the mouth to suck the
blood from an infant's foreskin penis
right I can't say that that has nothing
to do with Judaism I can accurately say
most Jews don't do that I can say most
Jews find it deplorable but Judaism is
still being used as a justification by
those who do it and to ignore that and
to pretend there's no role at all being
played would be very silly the argument
that without x/y person would still be
doing Z let's apply that to this
situation pad even without Islam
disaffected people impacted negatively
by u.s. foreign policy would be
committing acts of terror well some of
them might be but maybe not that when
when someone says is this is because of
Islam and because of the God that I
follow we can't ignore that even if we
believe that it's a misinterpretation it
and to say even without Judaic teachings
that may well be misinterpreted orthodox
jews would still be doing the penis
sucking circumcision rituals well it's
not totally clear and I think that we
can't ignore that reality yeah and these
religions are derived from books that
are you know chapters and chapters long
you know it's a very very thick and
books and books
yeah books and books any I mean you can
you can have a lot of different
interpretations from that and some
people are more peaceful in how they
look at it other people are more
fundamentalist you're gonna have a wide
range of spectrum it is not Islamic to
say that there is a disturbingly high
amount of terror coming from followers
of one religion you're not saying that
most people that follow the religion or
terrorist or bad people and a better
discussion is given that a small
percentage of Muslims are influenced to
commit these types of acts by their
religion how can we work in partnership
with moderate Muslims to prove
such acts in the future bearing your
head in the sand and pretending Islam
has nothing to do with any of this is
absolutely useless and lots of the memes
that are sometimes used by the left to
disconnect religion from violent actions
our means that the left usually destroys
when the right tries to use those memes
let me give you an example Donald Trump
says he's gonna do a ton of crazy stuff
ban Muslims you know at one point punish
women for having abortions burn of
punish people for flag burning all of
this stuff right when you confront
trumpets with a lot of these claims they
say we don't have to defend that because
Trump's not really going to do it he
doesn't really believe that we should do
those things the left accurately
correctly says no no no the default is
we should believe that Trump wants to do
what he says he wants to do if we have
terrorists saying they did this for or
because of their religion then at least
as far as they're concerned we should
believe that they did we can still say
that's a that that's a perversion you've
perverted the meaning of your religion
we can still have that conversation but
we shouldn't say they're wrong that's
not actually why they do it let me give
you another example the right often says
that tools don't matter in that common
phrase of theirs guns don't kill people
people kill people and the left
correctly responds to that by saying
wait a second people kill people with
the use of the guns that we give them
really easy access to in that same vein
when some on the left like to say
religion doesn't kill people
it's people that kill people well along
the same lines let's apply the same
critique people kill people
based on their understanding of and how
they are influenced by their religion
these are concepts Pat that the left
won't accept from the right but somehow
are sometimes willing to accept from
their own and I think it's clear that
Islamophobia exists but we shouldn't be
overly sensitized to it and never call
it out when we see it I think that's the
that's what a lot of the stems from and
if the argument is the interpretation of
his
my teachings need not be such that it
leads to real-world violence yes hell
yes I'm on board and now you're speaking
my language
but ignoring Islam as a motivating
factor for specific attacks makes no
sense and it is really counterproductive
when the left does it agree with me
disagree let me know on Twitter at D
Pakman thanks for watching this video
before you watch the next one
remember we're raising money to expand
the David Pakman show big league as well
as expand progressive activism go to
david pakman.com slash donate donations
of any size are much appreciated